[Music]
we made the point a lot on the show
because it's true that the entire
purpose of the democratic party's
immigration policy is to change the
population of the united states in a way
that guarantees they win every election
going forward this is effectively
electorate packing it's an assault on
democracy it devalues your vote
it's happening right in front of us and
we've said so out loud and every time we
do say it out loud the usual liars and
dummies who imagine themselves to be the
gatekeepers of our national conversation
throw a fit they become apoplectic they
call us the usual names boo hoo
and then after a few days that's the
most interesting part they inevitably go
back to bragging in public about how
they're using immigration policy to
change the population the united states
in a way that guarantees they win every
election going forward
it's unbelievable and then expect us not
to notice
jennifer rubin is a columnist at the
washington post
reuben is probably the dumbest person
ever to have a newspaper column she's
also highly aggressive so she does this
a lot because she's got no
self-awareness and she did just the
other day in print hoping no one would
notice but we did here's what she wrote
quote democratic hopes that demography
would deliver texas have not been wrong
but perhaps just premature the 2020
congressional race has suggested that
while the fight for hispanic votes
remains competitive the sprawling
suburbs on major texas cities are
increasingly moderate
oh
in other words crow's gen ruben the
great replacement plan is working
it's helping the democratic party that's
the whole point
well thanks for telling us that jen
ruben and let us know if it's racist to
read your column out loud
so hunter biden
in contrast to a lot of other people in
this country is in a really good place
right now he's become a painter finger
painting apparently and he's been
selling his works for hundreds of
thousands of dollars to unnamed foreign
buyers because that's totally legitimate
people criticized him for this what does
he think he doesn't care what you think
if i was going to choose something
you know to become an artist and
and subject yourself to that uh that uh
the normal and uh and uh criticism of
sharing your art to a wider audience
than your friends and family is uh
you know i
uh
at least in my book it's a pretty
courageous thing to do you seem to have
good spirits about you know this sort of
kind of crazed narrative around your
your painting you know i mean how do you
you know what's your response to the
people who are you know
coming after like the prices of the work
or just you know the the collectors i
mean what's been your response to that
other than
honestly it's kind of bla hard to blame
hunter biden for this i mean if
someone's going to pay you hundreds of
thousands of dollars for your art
a hobby you just taken up like 20
minutes ago
would you take the money of course you
would
you would do what you could get away
with 99 of people would
it's everyone else who's implicated in
this the people who are interviewing
hunter biden and calling any criticism
of his art career hyperventilating it's
all political it's the people buying
this crap purely because he's the
president's son
and it's the entire media establishment
pretending it's not happening
those are the villains in this story
hunter biden's just a man on the make
getting what he can and he's getting a
lot he just hosted an art show in
hollywood it featured hundreds of rich
people from around california including
the mayor of the rapidly disintegrating
city of los angeles eric garcetti he was
there
now why might that be because he's a
huge art fan because hunter biden after
50 years of running around smoking crack
or doing whatever he was doing became a
great artist right no
joe biden has just nominated garcetti to
be the american ambassador to india
garcetti you should know appears in
hunter biden's laptop on a list of key
contacts
to grease the wheels for hunter biden's
chinese business partners it's all so
repulsive it's actually happening now
it's so third world miranda devine has
chronicled it really like nobody else
she works at the new york post and we're
grateful to have her with us tonight
miranda have you purchased one of these
paintings uh no i haven't they're really
out of my price range we're talking
about you know up to five hundred
thousand dollars and um they don't
really strike me as being so good that i
want them on my walls
maybe as a novelty item i think maybe a
lot of people would be buying it because
hunter biden has become now so notorious
through his laptop one of three that
he's uh mislaid around the place and um
you know we can laugh at him and as you
say like he doesn't care he's
untouchable now his father is the
president
and whatever grift he's up to it's
really joe biden's gift it's the
president's grift and now it's the white
house grift and so it's everyone's
problem particularly the democrats and i
think anyone who goes to these hunter
biden art shows there's another one
happening in new york in the fall later
on um
they're you know if they go they are
legitimizing uh what is really um just a
racket
well the entire art world is a tax dodge
and i think that's that's well known to
rich people i'm not sure a lot of people
understand that but a lot of it's just
about tax avoidance of course but what
about all these so-called art critics
and
newspaper reporters who under any other
circumstances would be covering this
with at least some amusement and they're
totally ignoring it
yeah well it's like everything that's uh
plays badly for joe biden you saw it
before the election when we published
our stories on the laptop that was
suppressed and you've seen it ever since
anything that's negative about joe biden
is covered up and
excused and
explained away and any bad optics are
quickly mopped up that's i guess what
the white house is good at and we know
that hunter biden is under investigation
for money laundering among other
problems um and and we know that the art
world is notorious for being a venue for
money laundering so it's really takes a
lot of chutzpah for him to to do this
but that's the the by word i think of
the biden administration is
shamelessness it's shameless that the
president is it isn't even pretending to
distance himself from what's going on he
keeps on hiding behind this mirage of
being just a kindly uh fatherly family
man
when he's been in on this influence
peddling
enrichment program
from the start
none of these people ever do anything
useful like you're getting off drugs
good for you why not learn hvac repair
how to fix a diesel engine or how to
take drywall you know it's always some
bs fake career oh i'm a lobbyist you
know what i mean i'm a consultant i'm an
artist like none of it's real they can't
do anything these are useless people has
that occurred
well i mean it's not really
hunter's fault he was always brought
brought up to be the bag man
yeah no you're you're totally right i
agree
i've never i've never i've never blamed
him i feel sorry for him the people
around him are awful brandon thank you
for your reporting on this